[Música]
en la votación número 15 la cámara de
representantes de Estados Unidos por fin
logró ponerse de acuerdo y eligió
portavoz el republicano Kevin mccarthy
es el nuevo presidente del órgano
legislativo tras arduas negociaciones
con los ultraconservadores que
bloquearon las 14 elecciones previas
la Casa Blanca agradeció a México el
arresto del narcotraficante oído Guzmán
hijo de Joaquín El Chapo Guzmán Mientras
que el presidente de mexicano Andrés
Manuel López Obrador descartó que la
detención se haya planeado por la
inminente visita de Joe biden el
operativo de captura dejó 29 muertos
Ecuador cerró 2022 con el número más
alto de homicidios de su historia las
autoridades revelaron que se registraron
más de 4.500 asesinatos y detallaron que
la mayor parte de las muertes tienen que
ver con el crimen organizado y la lucha
por los territorios ampliamos desde
quito
Bienvenidos a esta informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos esta
emisión de noticias en Estados Unidos
porque Kevin mccarthy es el nuevo
presidente de la cámara de
representantes el republicano fue
elegido en la ronda número 15 de
votación tras una ardua jornada de
negociaciones en las 14 rondas
anteriores el boicot de los Ultra
conservadores había bloqueado su
elección medios estadounidenses
mostraron que al final de la votación 14
se produjo una llamada del expresidente
Donald Trump que habría podido ser
determinante en el resultado ahora
mccarthy reemplaza a Nancy pelosi como
portavoz del órgano legislativo y ocupa
el tercer puesto más importante del país
Andrés granadillo nos cuenta más de su
trayectoria
Kevin mccarthy es un hombre de 57 años
que vive en un Distrito conservador en
el estado demócrata por excelencia
California desde que llegó a Washington
en 2007 quiere presidir la cámara de
representantes en 2015 casi gana la
Silla cuando el republicano johner
anunció su renuncia pero los choques con
los representantes del freedom Cocos el
ala más conservadora de los republicanos
se lo impidieron cuando la entonces
presidenta de la cámara Nancy pelosi
inició uno de los juicios políticos
contra Donald Trump mccarthy fue uno de
los que se opuso
la presidenta de esta cámara pero no
habla por Estados Unidos cuando se trata
de este tema no puede decidir
unilateralmente lo que sucede aquí han
estado investigando a este presidente
incluso antes de que fuera electo han
votado tres veces sobre juicio político
Aquí
también hizo eco de las acusaciones
infundadas de fraude de Trump al perder
la presidencia y llamó a un recuento de
los votos
debe terminarse tenemos desafíos dentro
de los tribunales cada demanda debe ser
escuchada independientemente de a quien
apoye en esta elección al final del día
queremos que Estados Unidos esté Unido
Aunque republicano condenó el asalto del
Capitolio y denunció el comportamiento
de Donald Trump semanas después fue amar
al agua retractarse y a intentar
recuperar el aprecio del hombre que una
vez le llamó mi Kevin el portavoz de la
cámara de representantes es la tercera
persona con más poder en Estados Unidos
tras el presidente Joe biden y la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris en Perú las
protestas que sacudieron el país en
diciembre pasado tras el encarcelamiento
del destituido presidente Pedro Castillo
volvieron este dinero en forma de
bloqueos las manifestaciones son menos
numerosas y están más centradas en el
sur los manifestantes amplían ahora sus
peticiones a la presidenta Dina boluarte
contra quien la fiscalía abrió
diligencias por las muertes durante las
movilizaciones Rodrigo sedano con los
detalles
tercer día consecutivo de protestas y
bloqueos en Perú menos multitudinarias
pero con gran impacto en el normal
funcionamiento del país en las pancartas
y carteles se leen los mismos lemas que
iniciaron las protestas tras el
encarcelamiento de Pedro Castillo en
diciembre en al menos nueve regiones
donde se concentran las manifestaciones
hay medio centenar de bloqueos Incluso
en un aeropuerto el motivo del paro que
actualmente estamos realizando
es por la pobreza por la extrema pobreza
que existe
un nivel del Perú
prácticamente El Perú es rico en todo
pero sin embargo el capitalismo Lima se
lo lleva todo el presupuesto y no viene
casi nada para el cusco para el ministro
de defensa las protestas van sin embargo
mucho más allá citando reportes de
inteligencia asegura que se busca un
movimiento separatista en las regiones
fronterizas con Bolivia hemos recibido
ese tipo la información en los cuales
hay ciudadanos extranjeros que han
ingresado no solamente con la intención
de asustar la violencia sino integrar
esta idea separatista de una parte
región de nuestro país entre tanto Dina
boluarte hizo un llamado para tratar los
temas urgentes del país y lograr la paz
social anuncio que el próximo
lunes el acuerdo
en el que están representadas todas las
fuerzas políticas y sociales por su
parte la fiscalía general abrió
diligencias previas por las denuncias
contra boluarte por las cerca de 30
muertes durante la primera ola de
protestas en diciembre seguimos en
México porque el gobierno de Estados
Unidos agradeció a las autoridades
mexicanas por la captura de Ovidio
Guzmán hijo del narcotraficante Joaquín
El Chapo Guzmán que se produjo A solo
días de que el presidente Joey de viaje
a México esto Pese a que el mandatario
mexicano Andrés Manuel López Obrador
dijo que la detención no tenía relación
con la visita y descartó que vaya a ser
extraditado según las autoridades 29
personas fallecieron en medio del
operativo Marina sardinha tiene los
detalles
no habrás tradición inmediata a Estados
Unidos para Ovidio Guzmán El hijo del
narcotraficante Joaquín El Chapo Guzmán
un juez Federal concedió la suspensión
de oficio respecto a la extradición y su
ejecución se decreta de plano la
suspensión de oficio Respecto a los
actos consistentes en la deportación
expulsión extradición y ejecución para
el efecto de que no se ejecuten y el
quejoso quede en lugar en el que se
encuentre a disposición de este juzgado
solo en relación a su libertad personal
y no sea entregado al gobierno de los
Estados Unidos de América ni a ningún
estado diverso el presidente mexicano
Andrés Manuel López Obrador también
señaló que las tradiciones EEUU de alias
El ratón líder de los chapitos no será
Fast Track o rápida Pese a que el
departamento de Justicia estadounidense
lo reclama desde 2019 su captura el
jueves en Culiacán desató una ola de
violencia por parte del Cartel De
Sinaloa los narcos sembraron el terror
en la capital de Sinaloa con cortes de
vías secuestros de vehículos
afectaciones infraestructuras y decenas
de vuelos cancelados los enfrentamientos
con las fuerzas de seguridad dejan un
saldo de al menos 29 muertos más de 30
heridos y 21 detenidos 35 militares se
encuentran lesionados por arma de fuego
a quien se les está brindando la
atención médica en instalaciones
hospitalarias tanto civiles como
militares
Asimismo hasta el momento no se tiene
información de ningún civil inocente que
haya perdido la vida resultado de estas
operaciones
hace tres años y tres meses Culiacán
vivió escenas similares cuando El hijo
menor del Chapo Fue capturado por
primera vez posteriormente fue liberado
por orden de amlo para evitar ataques a
civiles ahora Ovidio Guzmán se encuentra
en Ciudad de México pero cerca de 4.500
efectivos permanecen desplegados en
Sinaloa y Estados cercanos Vamos hasta
Ecuador porque este país cerró el año
como uno de los más violentos de su
historia con más de quinientos
homicidios cometidos durante 2022 las
autoridades indicaron que se registraron
25 muertes por cada 100.000 habitantes
con un aumento tangible en los
asesinatos el sicariato y los
feminicidios Gustavo Ortega corresponsal
de France 24 en Quito nos amplió los
detalles
Ecuador superó la tasa de muertes
violientes de la región según datos en
las Naciones Unidas e información de la
policía nacional ecuatoriana revelada el
día de hoy que lo ubica en uno de los
países más violentos de la región con 25
muertes violentas por cada 100.000
habitantes según datos de la Policía
Nacional el año 2022 en el país andino
se produjeron 4539 homicidios lo que
representa un incremento de 114% en
comparación al año 2021 cuando la tasa
de muerte se contabilizó en 12 por cada
100.000 habitantes cuatro delitos
caracterizan el incremento de la
violencia en Ecuador asesinato sicariato
homicidio y femicidio en su mayoría
relacionadas con el crimen organizado y
la lucha de territorio para el
narcotráfico la tendencia de crecimiento
de los homicidios en el país pasó de 5,4
en el año 2017 a 25 por cada 100.000
habitantes en el año 2022 el año más
violento de la historia de Ecuador la
tasa de América Latina es de 18 muertes
según las Naciones Unidas mientras que
Ecuador ya superó la tasa a 25 muertes
por cada 100.000 habitantes mientras
Mientras que el 3 de enero de 2023 ya se
produjo la primera muerte violenta por
impacto de bala de un hombre en la
provincia de Santo Domingo de los
tsáchilas los especialistas aseguran que
las cifras aumentarán durante el año en
curso si el estado no toma políticas de
seguridad más contundentes cerramos en
Hawai donde continuó la erupción del
volcán kilauea el servicio geológico de
Estados Unidos alertó de la expulsión de
lava desde el jueves en principio se
emitió una alerta roja que ya bajó a
naranja para las autoridades pidieron
que se extremen los cuidados por el gas
volcánico compuesto principalmente por
dióxido de azufre que puede producir
dificultades respiratorias con estas
imágenes Nos despedimos gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]